it's monday the 11th of april
i am confident the chancellor writes to
the prime minister for an investigation
into his own financial affairs after
days of questions over his wife's tax
status and his u.s green card
a tense week ahead a warning from
ukraine's president russia military
vehicles
are heading east explosions heard in two
eastern cities overnight
and a move too from austrian to
austria's chancellor who's been here in
kiev and is going to moscow today we'll
tell you why
mind the gap the battle for the french
presidency now between emmanuel macron
and far-right candidate marine le pen
who's narrowed his lead
easter travel warning the busiest in
eight years with fears two over the
price of filling up the tank after
weekend oil protests
[Music]
lock down looting fighting for food in
the streets of shanghai as some run out
of supplies
i'm at buckingham palace as the queen
reflects on her recent bout of
coronavirus
it does leave one very tired and
exhausted doesn't it
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world gender x
as the us issues its first gender
neutral passport we'll hear from a
campaigner who's fought for the same to
happen here in the uk
when you're back on the raft you just
realize that that was so so close that
was literally fighting for your life
be joined by the british teenager who
survived a crocodile attack in zambia as
she prepares to return to help build a
school for the locals who helped through
the ordeal
[Music]
morning everybody please uh investigate
me that's the chancellor's request to
the prime minister this morning rishi
sunak has written to boris johnson
asking for his financial affairs to be
looked into it follows criticism about
his wife's tax affairs and his u.s green
card
in his letter to the pm mr sunak says
this my overriding concern is the public
retain confidence in the answers they
are given and i believe the best way of
achieving this is to ensure those
answers are entirely independent without
bias or favor to that end i would
recommend that lord geit makes all his
conclusions public i'm aware and
confident that such a review of my
declarations will find all relevant
information was appropriately declared i
have throughout my ministerial career
followed the advice of officials
regarding matters of propriety and
disclosure and will continue to do so
coming up we're going to be speaking to
the environment secretary uh and ask him
about that along with many other things
as well but first let's find out what's
happening in ukraine this morning and
explosions have been heard in two
ukrainian cities overnight as president
zielenski's warned russian troops are
ramping aggressions in the east of the
country
ukrainian media is reporting a series of
powerful explosions being heard in the
northeastern city of kharkiv as well as
in the southern city of microlife
it comes as president zielinski issued a
fresh warning that russian troops are
ramping up military aggression in
eastern ukraine
meanwhile the world bank is forecasting
that ukraine's economic output will
contradict oh forgive me will contract i
should bet say by more than 45
this year as the war forces businesses
to close let's take a closer look at how
the russian troops are believed to be
refocusing their military efforts after
failing to capture kiev western
intelligence suggests that russia will
now focus on consolidating their hold on
eastern regions such as luhansk and
donetsk with new images also showing a
large convoy heading towards the eastern
city of kharkiv
president zielenski has also sounded the
alarm in recent days over the key
southern port of odessa on the black sea
which is expected to come under renewed
attack
they can use more missiles against us
even more aerial bombs
but we are preparing for all of their
actions
we will respond
our defense and security editor deborah
haynes is joining us now live from kiev
this morning hello to debris so from
what we're hearing uh more and more
concern from the ukrainian politicians
that russia is regrouping for another
attack
yes we really are moving into the second
phase of this horrific war we're in the
seventh week now the capital is pretty
calm ukrainian forces here managed to
repel russian attempts to try to come
into the capital topple the leadership
and effectively impose a pro-moscow
government that didn't happen the
russian troops withdrew having sustained
significant losses in the words of their
own spokesperson and now they're moving
down to the east and the south where it
has been the scene for the last seven
weeks of heavy bombardments and the
expectation and all indications are that
there is going to be an even greater
onslaught down there and that is why
you're seeing many more civilians
evacuating despite the concern that
russian troops could be even targeting
the evacuation points and all the while
effort still to find some kind of
diploma diplomacy to work to end the
fighting and that's why you've got
austria's chancellor um heading to
moscow today to talk to vladimir putin
it's the first time a european union um
leader has uh had face-to-face
conversations with the um the head of
the kremlin he's been here um the the
austrian chancellor in kiev on saturday
the same day as british prime minister
was in town and now he's going to moscow
it's interesting because austria is a
military neutral country that means it's
not a member of nato and yet it's
positioned with regards to russia's war
of aggression which is the words that
the austrian chancellor uses is clear
and in a tweet um that he posted
yesterday evening about his trip he said
that his intention is to make sure that
the war stops um humanitarian corridors
a ceasefire and a full investigation
into war crimes are needed okay deborah
for now thanks so much indeed thanks a
lot we know that our own prime minister
was actually
in kiev uh over the weekend um joining
us now is the environment minister
george eustis hello to you mr eustis a
bit of a surprise that we saw our own pm
um in kiev cementing um i suppose the
conviction that the brits are doing what
they can to support ukraine in this
their hour of need
well absolutely in fact i think the
whole world is coming together to show
you know solidarity and support of
ukraine about what's happened that's why
the prime minister announced yesterday
that we would be making available more
you know defensive military equipment uh
to the ukrainians additional uh missiles
and so on we've been giving them support
from from the beginning but also it's so
important that we remain absolutely
resolute when it comes to sanctions
against russia we must ensure that putin
cannot prevail on this uh the ukrainians
have been incredibly uh brave i think
president zielenski has led his people
well and we've all been humbled really
by the the acts of bravery we've seen
but also deeply shocked about some of
these terrible scenes that we're seeing
coming out now from the cities from
which russia's withdrawn yeah an a-star
then for the support for ukraine on the
ground but must try harder when it comes
to refugees even priti patel the uh home
secretary apologizing for the fact that
we are not moving quickly enough to help
refugees who want to come to the uk
it's different for countries that are
bordering the ukraine because people are
fleeing a war like this obviously will
cross the nearest land border and that's
why countries like you know poland and
hungary obviously are getting
more of those refugees coming in but we
have now issued visas under the two
schemes we've got in particular the
sponsorship scheme to around 40 000
ukrainians and around 12 000 of those
are already here we've made some changes
already making clear for instance that
those with a ukrainian passport don't
need to attend an appointment in person
and i know that pretty patel is looking
very closely at this to look at whatever
else can be done how to remove any
barriers as and when those arise
yeah well um dublin doesn't border
um ukraine either but they're doing a
lot better than we are
well look there are as i said some
differences
between uh countries but uh priti
patel's already made some changes
removing that need uh for an appointment
in person for those with a passport and
she's also made clear that if there's
other things that we can do to speed up
the process we will and there's been a
huge outpouring i think of generosity
around the country different local
authorities seeking to be involved now
we financially supported around 27 local
authorities to stand up hubs and
reception centers to help refugees that
are coming here and i think many people
want to do their bit to help okay do you
understand why people are angry about
the revelations about rishi sunak and
his wife
well look rishi sunak and his wife are
spoken for themselves on this i'm not
his accountant i'm not responsible
obviously for his uh for his tax affairs
all those indeed of his wife she gave a
statement over the weekend she's uh now
made clear that although
she hasn't done anything wrong um you
know she
uh she's a
citizen of india and um i grew up and
was born in india and has some income
from that nevertheless she's changing
her tax arrangement so that she would
pay the tax on that income here in the
uk and rishi himself has been some
speculation around that he's
written to the prime minister and asked
the adviser on ministerial standards to
look at this case and he's very clear
that he's you know declared
everything that should have been
declared at the right time and there is
a process here that you have as a
minister you declare all your interests
to the permanent secretary in your
department and the cabinet office then
you know decide which bits should be
made public which bits they should be
aware of there's a duty of candor in
both directions and rishi's very clear
that he's uh that he's he's been very
candid about his uh his own arrangements
at every stage
and an answer to my question
uh will your question um uh was with are
people angry about this and i've just
said out um the position and and how
they've responded to it yeah do you
understand why the british people are
angry that the man who has increased tax
for them his wife was not paying
tax on overseas income to the um extent
of millions of pounds do you understand
why there is anger amongst the british
public on that
well look i think people should judge
the chancellor he is why don't you just
say yes i mean it's obvious it's obvious
i mean are you so out of touch as a
government that you don't understand
that people are struggling to feed their
kids whereas the man who's enforcing
these laws on them these taxes on them
his is rolling in it
well the man who uh is chancellor at the
moment has paid all of his taxes and
paid taxes on his uh income and declared
all of that in the uk and he's been
clear about that and that's you know we
of course there is a pressure on cost of
living at the moment we all recognize
that that we all recognize that there
are some difficult decisions coming down
the tracks when it comes to tax to help
get the nhs back on track but we're also
doing all that we can to help people
through these difficult times okay uh
what about his green card i know he's
given it up now but he was
chancellor when he had a green card for
residency in another country while he
was responsible for uk tax
well look he worked in the united states
and said for many years um he was based
out there lived out there worked out
there and yes there was a
if you like a hangover from that period
when he was working in the u.s where he
retained that green card but obviously
he got rid of that a couple of years ago
i think um
i'm sure he was still an mp
in october
well
he's got rid of the green card now but
what i'm saying
my point is he was responsible for uk
tax
while he was resident in another country
at that according to don't take it from
me according to some of your back
benches saying that it doesn't pass the
political cricket test that you're
committed to the uk
well all i'm saying is he worked in the
united states for a while during that
period he had a green card he kept that
green card for a period after that but
as i understand it it hasn't affected
the tax that he's paid here in the uk
that's not my point my point is that he
was a resident in another country and he
was responsible for what you and i and
my viewers this morning pay in tax how
does that pass the test of fairness
well he had a green card
a u.s green card and i'm not an expert
on that i've never had one myself nor
would i ever seek to have one to be
honest uh but look uh he's now referred
himself to
the adviser uh on uh standards of
ministerial interests uh lord guide
we'll look at all of this and will
you know make an assessment about
whether he declared all the right things
at the right time
um sergey javid now revealing that he
previously had non-dom status can you
anticipate anybody else in the cabinet
coming forward to say the same thing
well um i don't all i can tell you as i
said i'm not uh the accountant for my uh
ministerial colleagues in cabinet i
don't know anybody who may or may not
have had non-dom status i can tell you
uh that i never have and uh would never
seek to have one that's something we
have in common um should spices ever be
fair game
well look i think um
in reality i think when it comes to
politics we all know that there's a
heightened level of scrutiny for those
that get involved in politics and that
can affect family um should it i think
it probably shouldn't i think um
politicians who put themselves up into
public life um expect that higher level
of scrutiny often with that will come
some extra scrutiny on their family and
that's understood but i think um
generally no i think it should be the
focus on those elected politicians and
what they do principally in the job and
um and i think it's wrong that family
should be drawn into it in that way
do you think that we as the british
public should have any view on the fact
that mrs mercy although she's now saying
that she
will pay taxes on her foreign income
which could amount to many millions of
pounds she won't have to pay
inheritance tax because she's still
a non-dom that means she's going to save
potentially hundreds of millions of
pounds is that morally right
well as i said she is not the chancellor
and she's not in politics she's the one
if i may interrupt you there minister no
but she she was for a long time uh
living in taxpayer-funded accommodation
well and she has made clear and you know
she's spoken for herself on these
matters she's not part of the government
it's not for me really to speak for her
but she has spoken for herself on this
that she's going to change her tax
arrangements so that she does pay
income tax on the income that she earns
from overseas there's nothing wrong with
what she's been doing but she said
nevertheless that she will
make that payment going forward and i
think it's for her really to to speak
for her own affairs on these matters
it's not for me as i said i'm not her
tax advisor and she's not part of the
government it's not really for me to
speak for her or her entire individual
personal tax effects no but my point is
that she was living with the family in
taxpayer-funded accommodation and she
was saving many many millions of pounds
by using her non-dom status that has
been brought to the public's attention
and the um would-be prime minister has
now decided that that will not happen
going forward but it's now become
uncovered that um she won't have to pay
um
a tax on an inheritance or she won't
have to pay inheritance tax and i'm
asking you whether you feel uh you must
have a view do you feel that that is
morally right
well the chancellor who's part of the
government has now you know referred
himself
to lord gates and asked him to
investigate all of his own arrangements
all of his own tax affairs and what he
declared and what was made public on his
ministerial declaration at the time
that investigation will take place you
know the tax affairs of his wife are a
different matter and she has given an
account of that over the weekend made
clear that she intends to pay tax on
some of that foreign income going
forward and i think really you know it's
for her to talk about her own tax
affairs as i said i'm not qualified to
i'm not her accountant i'm not even an
accountant at all
but
um you are representing the government
this morning and you know that's right
she's not part of the government
no but she lived in taxpayer-funded
accommodation we've made that clear
she's married to a man who wants to be
prime minister who is charging uh people
millions of pounds in taxes that they
can ill afford at the moment half a
million kids are in uh real poverty have
been plunged into real poverty as a
result of what's happened over the last
few weeks and months does it not offend
you in any way
well look i'm somebody as a cabinet
colleague of uh rishi cena the
chancellor i judge ministerial
colleagues based on their performance in
the role and i think rishi sunak has
performed very well as chancellor of the
x-jacket doing some extraordinarily uh
difficult times and he himself has now
referred himself to
lord gait the minister the prime
minister's adviser on ministerial
sanders to look at these matters
and i i'm really not going to get drawn
into commenting uh you know any further
than i have on his wife's tax affairs he
said i'm not qualified to she's given an
account of those herself every mp's
family at some level you know leaving
what you might call taxpayer funded
accommodation because most mps obviously
uh you know maintain um a presence in
both london and in their constituencies
okay something i know that you do want
to talk about is the announcement that
your department is making today tell me
more
fly tipping has been a a really
difficult problem in recent years
and what we are announcing today is a
couple of things first of all removing
the charge that some local authorities
around a third of them still charge
people for disposing of
items like plasterboard if they've been
doing diy we're going to you know remove
their ability to charge for that to you
know remove one of those incentives
perhaps for people to fly to these items
are often
associated with flight equipment but
also linked to that on the enforcement
side we're supporting a number of local
authorities with some pilot schemes uh
using cctv in a creative way to try to
catch the criminals that are responsible
for fly tipping in most local
authorities it's a relatively small
number of people we want to help them
identify who they are so that we can
bring them to justice and stop this
problem okay minister i must let you go
i know but it's always great to talk to
you hopefully see you soon thank you
very much thank you very much
quick look at the morning's papers for
you let's start with the telegraph
leading on the news that chancellor
rishi sunak has referred himself as we
heard there from the minister to the
minister's interest watchdog after his
wife's non-dom status and the u.s
residency card he held while he was
chancellor came to light
the eye front page also has the same
story with the headline sunax hopes of
becoming pm evaporate the times says the
outcome of the french presidential
election hangs in the balance after the
incumbent emmanuel macron won the first
round of the vote the ft front page
pictures president macron
face to face with far-right candidate
marine le pen who came second in the
vote and will face him in the second
round of the election
well mr macron will face as we say the
far-right candidate in the french
presidential elections after making it
through the first round
misha macron took the highest share of
the vote with 27.6
ms le pen uh received a second highest
share with
23.4 percent she narrowly beat the far
right uh far left candidate forgive me
jean-luc melanchol to the final round of
voting
he came third there he is with 22 of the
vote sally lockwood reports now from
the big question dominating french
politics can the far right really win
after five years of president macron
french voters are deciding his future at
the ballot box he won the highest share
of the vote in this first round but it's
tight the full verdict is still two
weeks away and a second term for the
country's youngest ever premier appears
vulnerable
at this decisive moment for the future
of the nation nothing must be as it was
before
i would like to take the hand of
everyone who would like to work for
france to join me i'm ready to invent
something new
on the other side of paris president
macron has the same rival once again
as marine le pen arrived i asked if she
was feeling confident
a simple nod said it all this is the
far-right leader's third and final
attempt at the french presidency and if
you go by the polls she's never got as
close as this
marine le pen has presented a softer
more unifying image of herself in this
campaign
in this campaign i decided not to be
partisan to be at the service of all and
to directly address you
i will carry on doing so for the day
after the second round not to exclude
anyone to be the president for all the
french people
le pen's decision to focus on the cost
of living was a smart choice and won her
a broader church of voters
speaking less on immigration and islam
has helped to detoxify her brand
critics say she's changed her style but
not her far right values but this time
marine le pen is far more palatable to
many voters and those voters are far
less predictable
even marine le pen's past praise
vladimir putin didn't dent her support
during a horrifying war in ukraine the
overall impression is french people are
looking for a change
but that change could give vladimir
putin a perceived ally in the elysee
palace
france feels in unchartered election
territory
sally lockwood sky news paris
still to come on the programme for you a
former u.s nato defense official michael
ryan will be with us to discuss russia's
refocus in the east of ukraine and
whether nato is doing
enough as the us allows its citizens to
select a gender-neutral x on their
passport we'll speak to a campaigner
who's fought for the same to happen here
in the uk without success
drivers are being warned to expect the
busiest easter on record as millions of
britons prepare to hit the road this
weekend
however the suspension of sailings by
piano ferries has caused long tail backs
in and around dover the congestion is
reportedly costing transport companies
800 pounds per lorry as british haulers
of perishable goods complain the long
waiting times are causing
products to rot
inside the vehicles and it's not just
the ports that are under pressure
airports have reported long queues over
the past week as they struggled to find
staff to cope with the demand after many
lost their jobs
due to the pandemic covid also a big
problem we're told
and we'll have more on that in fact
from uh who we got simon calder i think
from the independent he's going to be
updating us on easter travel a bit later
on
meantime elon musk has decided not to
join the twitter board despite becoming
the company's single biggest shareholder
the social media giant ceo para agarwal
said that the tesla found a related
decision on the very morning he'd been
due to be officially appointed musk
appeared to have been looking forward to
joining the board tweeting on thursday
that its next meeting was gonna be lit
down with the kids let's look at some of
today's other headlines for you now
should we and johnny depp's
multi-million dollar u.s defamation
lawsuit against his ex-wife amber hurd
is due to begin at a virginia courthouse
later on today he claims he was wrongly
accused of domestic abuse in an article
she wrote for the washington post
a serving metropolitan police officer
will go on trial today accused of trying
to meet a 13-year-old girl
after online grooming detective
constable francois alwaghi is accused of
a number of offenses including
attempting to engage in sexual
communication
with a child
pakistan is expected to appoint an
interim prime minister later on today on
saturday imran khan was ousted after
losing a vote of no confidence the vote
was called after his opponents
criticized him for not tackling
corruption
the queen's been speaking about her
spell of coronavirus during a virtual
meeting of hospital staff in london
i'm glad that you're getting better and
you and it it does leave one very tired
and exhausted doesn't it
sure does madeleine is at buckingham
palace for us this morning hi madeline
we knew that she'd had coronas
coronavirus we didn't really know how
badly she'd been impacted by it until
now
good morning kay um that's right when
the queen tested positive in february
for coronavirus buckingham palace said
she was suffering from mild cold-like
symptoms but it's now that the queen has
revealed how like so many other people
struggling with the virus she felt very
tired and exhausted as well and she was
speaking via video link at
the official award opening of the queen
elizabeth unit at the royal london
hospital um talking virtually with
nurses there who would work throughout
the pandemic and indeed with the
sufferer that clip you had there was her
talking to assaf hussein who had been on
a ventilator in hospital for seven weeks
with coronavirus and he told the queen
about how his he had struggled with the
virus and that's when she revealed how
it had left her tired and exhausted as
well and how it wasn't a very nice
result at all
since the queen's diagnosis in february
she's obviously had to pull back on a
lot of engagements lots of them have
been virtual
um and and that includes this week where
she's um had to cancel her appearance at
the monday thursday ceremony ahead of
easter prince charles will do that
instead okay absolutely thank you
unrest is growing in the chinese city of
shanghai after weeks of strict lockdown
to curb covert cases in the region city
of 26 million people has been under
intense restrictions since the 28th of
march with residents only allowed to
leave their homes once a day to collect
food
sky news has verified these pictures of
looting in shanghai that were shared on
social media people can be seen grabbing
boxes and taking them away
tom standing by for us in beijing today
um hi tom you predicted that this was
going to happen
morning k i mean i think it's really
hard to predict anything that's
happening with shanghai as you say is an
incredibly strict lockdown but what
everyone's been surprised by is just how
chaotic it has been on top of that
before this lockdown people were
reprimanded for spreading rumors as
authorities called it that there might
be a lockdown that lockdown went ahead
but the food supplies haven't been there
that's why you're seeing pictures like
this residents aren't allowed to go to
supermarkets as they were during the uk
lockdown for instance they have to rely
on the government to deliver food and
those suppliers in many instances have
not been getting through we've seen
looting scenes like that uh pictures
you're seeing now of a compound air
called kanting in
shanghai where residents were
confronting officials and police saying
we need food we demand supplies so there
is that frustration growing um but it
doesn't look like it's going to stop any
time soon shanghai reporting 26 000
cases might not sound like much compared
to the average sort of uk numbers but
again it's a new record
and that's why they are sticking with
this dynamic zero kovid policy as they
call it now shanghai is at the eye or in
the eye of this storm but there are
concerns all around the country that
these sorts of scenes might be repeated
guangzhou which is a huge city in the
south a manufacturing hub uh is entering
some new restrictions it's mass testing
all its 18 million residents and even
here in beijing which hasn't had much in
the way of kovid there have been
residential compounds being locked down
just as we saw in the early days of
shanghai just a few weeks ago really um
so that question of whether china will
alter its policies i think we had a
pretty clear answer from xinhua the
official state news agency uh they said
it would be disastrous if china
abandoned covered syria the medical
system will be overwhelmed so they're
going to keep going with this strategy
until they get back down to somewhere
near zero okay for now tom thank you
thanks a lot
what's happening as far as the weather
is concerned let's find out
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
southerly wind will make it warmer over
the next few days but will bring rain at
times fairly mild generally although
parts of northeast scotland are frosty
but it's windy in the south and the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
have a look at this
what spanish police have uncovered the
civil guards are investigating a
businessman in valencia with a private
taxidermy collection with more than a
thousand stuffed animals including just
over 400 from protected species and at
least one
already extinct the collection is
estimated to be worth almost 30 million
euros on the black market but its owner
could now be charged with possible
trafficking and other crimes against the
environment if he loves animals so much
why doesn't he just go and see them in
the wild rather than stuffing a cheetah
and thinking it's cool because it's not
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show this monday morning
here on sky news top stories for you the
chancellor rishi sunak has written to
the prime minister to ask for an
investigation into his financial affairs
to determine whether all his interests
were properly declared
explosions have been heard in two
ukrainian cities overnight as president
zielinski warned that russian troops are
ramping aggressions in the east of the
country
and emmanuel macron will face marine le
pen in a runoff for the french
presidency after the two make it through
the first round of voting
a government minister has said an
investigation into the chancellor's tax
arrangements will discover whether he
declared the right things at the right
time the environment minister was
speaking to this programme after rishi
sunak asked the prime minister to refer
him to lord gait the independent adviser
on minister's interests after days of
criticism over his wife's tax affairs
himself has been some speculation around
that he's uh written to the prime
minister and asked the adviser on
ministerial standards to look at this
case uh he's very clear he's you know
declared everything that should have
been declared at the right time
and there is a process here that you
have as a minister you declare all your
interests to the permanent secretary in
your department and the cabinet office
then you know decide which bits should
be made public which bits they should be
aware of there's a duty of candor in
both directions and rishi's very clear
that he's uh that he's he's been very
candid about his uh his own arrangements
at every stage
ali is here this morning this is not
going away is there no it's not still
recess but this definitely isn't going
away i thought we had some interesting
answers there from george eustis because
he said he doesn't think the
chancellor's done anything wrong he
effectively sort of welcomed the
chancellor calling for this inquiry to
look into his financial affairs but he
also i think wanted to distance himself
from it in a way because my
interpretation yeah that's what that was
my take what exactly he meant we don't
know but i think he said he did say a
couple of times on non-dom and on the
green card he said i personally wouldn't
have done that he said i've never know
but i ever seek to have non-dom status
and for me that i thought was quite
telling and i think the problem for
people isn't necessarily that the
chancellor is a very wealthy man
although clearly that was brought in
sharp focus last week it's about this
sort of sense of fairness isn't it and
even if we have this inquiry now and
even if the chancellor is found to have
abided by the letter the law it's it's
the spirit of the law and it's how these
things are perceived and we heard his
wife herself admitting she said and
there is a british sense of fairness
before she agreed to change the way that
she pays tax in this country okay what
about the family moving out of downing
street are we reading anything into that
well they say the the interpretation is
it is so they can be closer to their
daughter's school and she's in her last
year primary school um
i think you know people will make their
own judgments obviously the timing is
interesting um but we do understand that
they are moving to their west london
home they're going to be spending more
time there um not in downing street and
i think you know the context of all of
this the cost of living crisis that's
the other thing that people are that
people are sort of struggling with even
if he's a wealthy man
that's not necessarily as i say the
problem the problem is can he really
relate to people and he's given his
green card back he had it while he was
chancellor of course one wonders if
anything whether the u.s state
department might have anything to say i
don't know we'll have to wait and see
but i know i've got ali's cake coming up
at nine o'clock
thank you very much indeed returning now
to the situation in ukraine where
president zielenski has warned that
russia will intensify its military
action in the east of the country let's
speak now to michael ryan the former
deputy assistant secretary of defense
for europe and nato hello to you thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us on the programme this morning um
what's your overall your overarching
view of what's happening in ukraine at
the moment
good morning kay thank you for having me
the russians have clearly reassessed
their objectives in the war focused
primarily on the east
their major problem is that they have to
reconstitute enough what we refer to as
combat power the ability to fight
effectively in the east and then take on
a very entrenched and very experienced
ukrainian force that has been preparing
for them for a long time so the next
three weeks will be decisive it will
determine the outcome of the war and if
we the west can increase our sense of
urgency in supplying the ukrainians
perhaps up to the level of the berlin
airlift the ukrainians can really come
out of this with a victory
i believe the u.s national security
adviser jake sullivan saying that he
expects russia's newly appointed
general to be either i think his name is
alexander duromnikov um to be even more
uh bloody and determined to break the
soul of the ukrainian people
yes i agree with that assessment the
russians are medieval they're brutal but
they're not stupid and so they learn and
they've learned quite a lot about how
the ukrainians are fighting so i believe
the general will go back to classic
russian tactics they'll do massive air
and artillery assaults on the ukrainian
positions
before they throw a lot of tanks and a
lot of soldiers at them but it's going
to be a difficult proposition for them
because we just don't assess that they
have the energy to be able to carry off
that sort of campaign and it will cause
a lot of brutality as president zolensky
has predicted it'll look like world war
ii as the ukrainian foreign foreign
minister said
at the end of the day the russians are
going to suffer even more casualties in
this approach
we continue to hear that
president putin
wants to de-escalate the situation in
ukraine should we believe him
well frankly i don't believe so because
the negotiations are now at a state
where neither side really feels they
have a strong position
and war is a continuation of policy by
other means and president putin's policy
obviously is the subjugation of ukraine
and so anything that he says
that tries to disguise that fact i would
not take uh as truth
so given that you were previously the
assistant defense secretary for europe
and nato what's what's your
interpretation of what his plan is
what's his end game
i think given the success of the
ukrainian military his end game is
shifting his personal end game has to be
to stay in power and i think we have to
look at everything that he does through
the lens of that
because he doesn't have a lot of other
options once he leads government in
russia
and so his end game is to stay in power
which means he has to play to the
domestic audience which means he has to
come out of this with a victory and so
enhancing the position of the russians
in eastern ukraine
in
essentially the russian-speaking areas
of ukraine by taking a a land border a
land bridge if you will from the
donbasque down towards the black sea and
enhancing the overall state of the
russians ability
to claim that they're supporting russian
speakers in ukraine i think will be
enough of a victory for him
to consolidate his gains sue for peace
achieve some level of
sanctions relief through negotiation and
then wait us out wait a few years and
try again
is that too much of a defeat for
zolensky though
yes kay i do believe it is i can't see
any negotiated settlement that results
in the ukrainians giving up even more
territory as being acceptable
zolensky and he has rightly said
whatever negotiations result
he has to put that to the ukrainian
people for their support
and i don't think they'll ever accept
that
um
in the meantime i was looking at
pictures of our own prime minister
actually who was
in kiev at the weekend
we know that your president president
biden is hoping to speak to the
leader of
india president modi
we also know that india is still an ally
shall we say of russia and taking cut
price fuel from russia
do you think that president biden
speaking to modi will make any
difference at all to the relationship
between india and russia
well i think we're in this situation
with india of incremental changes over
time the indians are geographically
situated between the chinese the
russians and the west and they're being
very careful on how they're hedging
they clearly need the support of the
west
in their comp competition with china and
they balance
their relationship with russia to be
able to maintain a level playing field
if you will from their point of view i
think president biden will have some
influence the united states and the
europeans have a great deal to offer the
indians and the indians are being very
coy as to how they're going to position
themselves for the outcome of this
conflict but i think very gradually
president biden's influence in the
influence of
prime minister johnson and other
european leaders i will bring the
indians more on side as they see that
the ukrainians are going to come out of
this
war with the russians in a better
position
okay we appreciate you i don't know
getting up early or staying up late for
us i'm not sure which one it was but
either way we do appreciate it here on
the program this morning thank you
thank you very much kay have a great day
thank you you too
well uh from today u.s citizens will be
able to select the gender neutral x as a
marker on their passports in a move
announced last month by president
biden's administration to support
transgender americans i speak to
christie ellen kane a campaigner who
took the uk government to court in
december for not offering gender neutral
passports here in the uk morning to you
thanks for joining us on the program
when you see what's happening
in the u.s christie how's that
well i'm really pleased for people in
the us i think it's brilliant that the
states have joined a growing number of
companies
countries globally that have taken this
progressive move it's just really
unfortunate that the uk
doesn't seem to be able to grasp that
ex-pass sports are necessary for some
people including myself and thousands of
people in the uk
and uh
and and in the states and and globally
and the
x has been for some time
a permitted option and
in accordance with the international
standards but
it's up it's been uh
down to individual nations if they want
to
actually incorporate the ex into their
own policy
and some countries chose to do that at
an early stage like new zealand um
australia
more recently canada malta
and a number of countries in south
america colombia
argentina
uruguay and and now the states which i
think will hopefully be a game changer
whether that would make the uk
government see sense and and uh
and get on the right side of history
remains to be seen but
i i've gone as far as i can
in the legal system in this country and
so we my legal team and i are going to
be now
taking the case to strasbourg although
strasbourg wouldn't be able to undo
the
uk ruling as it were
but i'm hoping that it might be a
wake-up call for for
countries that haven't and i don't think
there's anywhere that i know of that has
been as slow to act as the uk where this
issue has been raised because
most governments can seem to accept that
there is a need for ex-passports and and
it's something that is basically
very uncontroversial in that it doesn't
harm anybody else it's just giving
people such as myself that
i do not identify as male or female it
means that i'd be able to have a neutral
passport that wouldn't force me to
declare
an inappropriate gender and had to carry
that that
passport that document around which is
supposed to be
an identity document and it has a
gendered reference that i don't identify
with and to me that that's fundamentally
wrong
you've answered all of the questions i
had for you christy so i shall allow you
to go and have a good morning thank you
very much for joining me okay thank you
thank you very much thanks a lot
i want to talk to you more about what's
happening as far as the easter breaks
are concerned um and simon calder who is
the travel editor of the independent um
is somewhere fabulously exotic for us
this morning hi simon where are you
uh good morning from beautiful como in
northern italy okay i managed to beat
the cancellations and fly out here on
saturday night a little bit late but my
goodness me it's lovely to be here uh
looking forward to a a gorgeous day
pretending to work
while of course being on holiday but
there are still a huge number of
cancellations around i have just counted
at least 100 cancellations of short haul
domestic and european flights by both
british airways and by easyjet today now
ba which is uh i i make it cancelled 58
says that all of those were kind of
decided a week or two ago and therefore
people have had plenty of warning to
get their new
flight arrangements in place easyjet
seem to be about 48 hours notice uh the
law fortunately is very much on the
passenger side if your flight is
cancelled then the airline has to give
you uh another flight even if they it
has to buy you a ticket on a different
airline and furthermore if you've been
given less than two weeks notice it will
always also be paying you compensation
yeah which all sounds fabulous but um
given that so many flights are being
cancelled there's no guarantee that even
if your airline's not taking you
there'll be another airline available to
do that
well yeah there's a lot of pressure on
seats at the moment both ba and easyjet
say that um the the problem is really to
do with high levels of covet infection
among their their staff um having said
that i think we have one jet two
cancellation possibly and one whiz air
cancellation at the weekend compared
with a couple of hundred on ba and
easyjet so you can assess that um there
is a fair amount of space around
during the early part of this week
the weekend was very high pressure but
there there are some
some spaces now and actually on the
ferry front things have slightly
improved after the weekend piano ferris
still isn't sailing between dover and
calais those three big ships still tied
up in
dover but uh dfds ferries which is a
rival
shipping company which has been mostly
carrying passengers for pno um has said
right as from today you can carry on uh
sailing with us and meanwhile between
karen ryan and lahn p o ferris has
resumed sailing so there are now three
uh voyages a day each way which will
take the pressure off stenner line
having said that um of course a lot of
people have said they really don't want
to say all that much on uh piano ferries
after the way that they treated 800 crew
yeah i think ba apparently trying
desperately to recruit lots of p o staff
as quickly as they possibly can to try
to alleviate some of the issues uh
looking at pictures from spain always
love a bucket of spade holiday in spain
as a family don't we but um
brits going to spain at the moment there
are still some uh challenges in place
when it comes to covid restrictions are
those being lifted
oh it's been a horrible horrible week
particularly people who for whatever
reason are not vaccinated
wednesday
lunchtime the spanish tourist office in
london said right we've opened up
anybody who isn't fully jabbed as long
as you have a pre-departure test lateral
flow will be absolutely fine then you
will be able to uh
travel to spain without any problems
unfortunately
uh they then retracted that um eight
hours later
um in the sense that they effectively
said we we misinterpreted an official
bulletin and having studied it i can see
how they would do it so unvaccinated
travelers to spain are still not welcome
the one change has been that if you are
fully jabbed and if boosted if the
second jab was over 270 days ago then
you no longer need to fill in that pesky
passenger locator form but one other
country which is uh this morning um that
said no more restrictions is the czech
republic which is joining poland and
hungary in saying oh just come on in no
need to fill any forms no proof of your
jabs um come and have a lovely holiday
and that's i think uh competitive
re-opening trying to attract us back
after two years of um effectively no
real tourist industry is going to be
happening more and more across europe
okay where's the best place to find
up-to-date information i was flying back
on an airplane from africa a couple of
weeks ago and
the announcement on
via the stewardess was that we still
needed to fill in our passenger locator
forms i pointed out to the stewardess
that wasn't the case and she said yeah
but i just read what's on the sheet
there's an awful lot of that yeah we've
been
we've been making these announcements
we've been saying this stuff and the
fact that it doesn't apply anymore is is
irrelevant it's so so difficult so i'm
here in this um uh lovely if rather
expensive for me hotel and um
i was handed a serious piece of paper
when i came in saying um you've got to
go and get a separate test from the
local pharmacy in order to be able to
allow in the breakfast room because
there's seven months since my booster
and that that matters in italy
apparently anyway i didn't and i was
allowed to have my very nice uh
breakfast and that's gone for all the
restaurants that i've
been obliged to test so far so it is
very muddled the only way to find out
what the rules are for your country that
you're going to is well i always check
with the foreign office first of all
search online for foreign office and the
name of the country but then i double
check with the tourist
site or indeed the embassy in london to
make sure i understand what the rules
are and then even so coming to italy i
filled out the pesky european digital
passenger locator form was anybody
remotely interested no they no they're
not
simon enjoy lake como great part of the
world thank you
quick look at what the papers are inside
uh are looking at marlon's done these
for us today this is the times which has
a lovely picture of lily the donkey
greeting a young boy ahead of palm
sunday this weekend is going to be
leading the first palm sunday procession
since 2019 to ripon cathedral very very
pleased indeed not quite sure
donkeys can bite you know ginger nuts
that's what you need
[Music]